toi je t'aime bien parce que tu as pu ce
film nous on a plein d'imagination on a
plein d'idées les Français n'ont rien du
tout à envie aux américains où est où je
jure de le tuer pr garde d'artagnon
cette femme t'a enjouté nous sommes des
tueurs d'Artagnan que cela vous plaise
ou
non n j'ai pas dit oui tout de suite je
redoutais un peu de de jouer ce rôle
comme ça qui est iconique et assez
intimidant même quand on m'a
mentionné cette opportunité sans avoir
lu le script j'étais et puis pourquoi
encore une 1è version des mous
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi et c'est
vraiment en lisant le le scénario que
que j'ai trouvé ça très moderne une
nouvelle vision des choses quelque chose
de plus viscéral plus dark parfois qui
qui rend le le matériel plus plus
profond et riche et le personnage de
Milady aussi il y a quelque chose de
moins insondable quand même et on va
découvrir dans le deuxième volet
pourquoi elle est devenue cette femme
sans
scrupule moi je suis pas non plus un un
exp per de toute sa filmographie que
j'aurais revu CIN fois avant de lui
proposer le rôle c'est pas du tout ça
c'est Eva je la connais évidemment comme
tout le monde mais en réalité quand je
parle de d'elle en tant que femme
actrice française elle a un certain
mystère qui fait partie de sa
personnalité publique beaucoup de
personnes peuvent s'imaginer qu'elle
n'est pas que française savent pas si
elle est française ou anglaise elle a
finalement beaucoup plus joué dans des
films anglo-saxon que des films français
et ça ça participe aussi quelque part
d'un petit mythe c'est atant comme
n'importe qui c'est attirant pour un
réalisateur et ça l' est pour un
spectateur je pense Eva elle a quelque
chose de très rare c'est qu'elle a une
cinginiie très
puissante il se passe forcément toujours
quelque chose quand on la filme elle a
des yeux elle a un regard la
caméra aime la filmer je sais pas
comment vous dire un plan d'écoute que
ça soit au 50 mm au 80 mm pour rentrer
un peu dans les détails techniques en
contreplongé en plongé dans un traveling
il y a toujours quelque chose qui fait
que il y a une force à l'image grâce à
son à sa présence pour un M en scène
c'est
extraordinaire ah oui c'est gnial moi
c'est ce que j'ai préféré dans ce film
dans la préparation c'est tout le
travail avec l'équipe de Mario lorci
pour les
chevaux avec les cascadeurs aussi
c'était c'était très amusant très
physique j'étais très gauche au début et
après on acquiert de la la confiance et
on sent plus à l'aise bizarrement ça
aide aussi à trouver un peu le
personnage la virilité du
personnage
al il y a peut-être deux choses dans ce
que vous avez dit les chev en général
j'ai pas trop confiance ils sont assez
imprévisibles mais Mario lur est un
sorcier et j'ai été absolument bluffé
par par ses chevaux par par Marg
passfort aussi qui était mon
instructrice qui était absolument
fabuleuse on a galopé à travers les
champs ensemble et c'était un vrai rêve
et je me suis étonné moi-même et puis le
feu oui j'ai une scène de combat dans le
feu et ça j'ai découvert ça le jour même
parce qu'on avait jamais répété ça
c'était très très très impressionnant et
wou l'adrénaline était à 100
%. faut être très concentré et parce
qu'on dépend de l'autre ça peut tourner
mal très vite c'est comme une danse donc
c'était très important de de répéter en
amont avec François civil donc on on
savait comment danser vous êtes soldat
pour
mourir je vous emmène là où
[Musique]
Me François est très très
perfectionniste intense il est très
précis en même temps il a une très
grande maturité il est très intérussi et
intéressé par le ce que derrière la
caméra je vois que je crois qu'il y a
quelque chose je sais pas il a je suis
sûr qu'il a quelque chose de m en scène
aussi il est très curieux et très
généreux aussi avec les acteurs il est
très très humble et ça c'est c'est
formidable de travailler avec
lui évidemment le bonde mais moi j'aime
bien quand les gens ont vu des films
indépendants ou des films qui ont moins
d'exposition donc ça tout de suite je je
genre ah mais toi je taime bien parce
que tu as pu ce
film les Français n'ont rien du tout à à
envier aux Américains c'était c'était
extrêmement merveilleux d'être tous les
jours sur des décors naturels parce
qu'il y a beaucoup les film américains
on a beaucoup d'écrans vert alors là
c'est c'est encore mieux que les films
américains c'est que tout était dans des
dans des vrais décors des des monuments
historiques et des centaines de
figurants en en costume extraordinair
c'est magique c'est qu'en France euh on
a les ressources pour proposer des des
des grands films blockbuster comme vous
le disiez mais surtout des des grands
film avec une ambition de cinéma forte
on a les ressources euh en terme de
d'auteur on a les ressources en terme de
de technicien d'acteurs on a les
histoires c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
revisite cette histoire qui avait pas
été faite en France depuis 60 ans donc
euh c'est vrai qu'il y a aucune raison
euh qu'on n'ose pas en tout cas aller
sur le même territoire que certaines
productions anglo-saxones qui s'adresse
au public avec comme ça une envie de
spectacle et de d'ambition
cinématographique forte donc on a les
producteurs et on sait faire donc oui si
ça il faut continuer à le faire
oui c'est toujours intéressant de de
jouer des personnages qui sont pas clair
au début on devine pas tout de
suite ce qui se passe qui ce qui se
circule c'est intéressant de découvrir
des couleurs au fur et à mesure de de du
film et en effet des les secrets des
Fiss
qui qui apparaissent comme ça au fil du
film c'est toujours
intéressant alors le film Dirty Angels
est un des rô les plus physiques que
j'ai fait c'est une soldat américaine
qui qui retourne en Afghanistan après le
départ des troupes c'était costaud dans
tous les sens du terme parce que si les
soldats ont un mental fort mais il y a
des surtout quoi après que si on a fait
la guerre en Afghanistant il y a il y a
beaucoup de fissures aussi donc c'est
encore un personnage qui est qui est
complexe comme vous dites
Martin Campell alors lui déjà il a il a
78 ans maintenant et je trouve qu'il a
encore plus d'énergie maintenant
qu'avant il a plus d'énergie que moi je
n'ai jamais rencontré un homme comme ça
il est passionné et je suis on est fait
très reconnaissante qui m' fait
confiance une seconde fois en plus dans
un rôle où je pense onentend pas du tout
donc oui oui je suis très
[Musique]
reconnaissante crack le film crack
Jordan Scott je trouve que c'est un très
bon film et très très beau et c'est un
personnage assez barré j'aurais aimé que
ça ait plus d'exposition mais peut-être
comme les bons vins après des années ça
devient quelque
chose moi je pense que c'est vraiment au
public de de de décider là je pense que
si ils aiment ce second volet je pense
qu'il y en aura un troisième nous on a
plein d'imagination on a plein
d'idéesant ces deux films ils ont été
faits ensemble ils ont été fabriqués
ensemble dans la même logique cétait une
proposition risquée et audacieuse de la
part des producteurs autant aujourd'hui
à 5 jours de la sortie on n pas le droit
de dire qu'on en fera forcément un tro
ça sera vraiment au spectateur de le
décider d'une certaine manière s'il en a
envie on saura lui proposer des idées
mais aujourd'hui on on est dans une
position sincèrement très humble par
rapport à la sortie de ce film on verra
bien c'est sûr que la fin nous amuse moi
j'avais à cœur aussi de projeter avec
les auteurs une une perspective mais euh
on verra c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
rien n'est décidé et on ser évidemment
être à l'écoute et réceptif au retour du
public je rappeler les flic Tura au
contraire le français ma langue
maternelle donc peut-être plus de
liberté moins conscient de la langue on
se dit là c'est sûr que j'ai pas de
faute de langue donc c'est non il y a
plus plus d'essence quand
même dernièrement comme ça j'ai j'ai
beaucoup aimé le règne animal de Thomas
Cay que j'ai trouvé extrêmement poétique
et audacieux je vous tue si vous me tuez
vous ne serez jamais constance merci
beaucoup merci merci à vous merci
beaucoup pour vos réponse merci à vous
Martin
merci